[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اثار حديث الرئيس السوري لشبكه اي بي سي
الامريكيه لغطا عندما حاول على ما يبدو
الناي بنفسه عن اعمال القتل التي ترتكبها
قوات بلاده ضد المحتجين وبينما انتقدت
واشنطن ما سمته سعي الاسد للتنصل من
مسؤولياته ردت دمشق بان اقوال الاسد حرفت
واخرجت من
سياقها
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين هل سعى الاسد بالفعل للناي بنفسه
عن اعمال القتل التي تتهم قواته بارتكابها
ضد
المحتجين لماذا لا يزال الاسد متمسكا
بالروايه الرسميه للاحداث في سوريا رغم
الرفض الواسع
[موسيقى]
لها في المقابله حاول الاسد على ما يبدو
حاول رسم خط فاصل بينه كرئيس وبين الاجهزه
الامنيه المتهمه بملاحقه المحتجين بالقتل
والتعذيب والاعتقال مبينا ان القوات
الامنيه تابعه للحكومه وانه رئيس للبلاد
لا غير غير ان الاسد لم يتخلف المقابله عن
الروايه الرسميه للاحداث الجاريه في بلاده
منذ اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر متجاهلا الشكوك
الواسعه التي تلقاها هذه الروايه محليا
واقليميا
ودوليا انها قوات عسكريه تنتمي للحكومه
انا لا املكها انا رئيس انا لا املك البلد
لكن عليك ان تعطي
الاوامر ليست اوامرك كلا كلا ليس بناء على
طلب من احد لم يكن هناك امر لقتل الناس او
للتعامل
بوحشيه الناس فرت من بيت لاخر والاطفال
اعتقلوا رايت هذه
الصور كيف تتحقق من هذه الصور لهذا نتحدث
عن مزاعم كاذبه وتشويها للحقائق نحن لا
نقتل شعبنا ليس هناك شخص او حكومه في
العالم تقتل شعبها ما لم يكن على راسها
رجل
مجنون ولمناقشة
اسقاط
نظامه ومما جاء على لسان الاسد في
المقابله التلفزيونيه مع شبكه اي بي سي
الامريكيه ان معظم الذين قتلوا من انصار
الحكومه مشيرا الى ان من بين القتلى 1
ومائه من افراد الجيش والشرطه وحول
اتهامات مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده للنظام السوري بارتكاب جرائم قال
الاسد ان مسؤولي الامم المتحده لم يقدموا
وثائق واعتبر الاسد ان الامم المتحده
منظمه ليس لها مصداقيه مبررا وجود سفير
لبلاده فيها بالقول انها لعبه نلعبها ولا
يعني ذلك اننا نصدقها وقال الاسد ان كل
تصرف وحشي من قبل افراد القوات المسلحه
كان تصرفا فرديا وليس مؤسسيا واعتبر الاسد
ان شعبيته في الداخل ما زالت مرتفعه واضاف
انه حينما يشعر بان التاييد الشعبيه له
تراجع لن يظل هنا وعندما سئل عما اذا كان
يشعر بالذنب جراء اعمال القتل اجاب بانه
لا يمكنه ان يشعر بالذنب عندما يبذل قصار
جهده واضاف ان المر يشعر بالاسف على
الارواح التي فقدت لكنه لا يشعر بالذنب
عندما لا يقتل الناس لذلك الامر لا يتعلق
بالذنب ضيوفي الكرام اهلا بكم مجددا ابدا
معك سيد محمد عبيد من بيروت اذا الرئيس
الاسد لا يشعر بالذنب هو مجرد رئيس لا
البلد لم يصدر اي قرار لهذه القوات التي
لا تعنيه
بالقتل لا يصدق الامم المتحده هي لعبه
نلعبها وهذا لا يعني اننا
نصدقها ما
رايك انا اعتقد
ان كما قيل ان هذا الامر تم تحريفه بشكل
او
باخر عفوا تم تحريف هذه
التصريحات الان توضحت اكثر من خلال هذا
هذا التقرير الذي قدمتموه المهم ان الرئيس
الاسد لم يتنصل من المسؤوليه هو فقط شدد
على انه ليست هناك اوامر لجهه قتل الناس
وان المسلحين الاصوليين المنتشرين في اكثر
من مكان منذ احداث درعا والان في محيط حمص
وعلى اطراف مدينه حمص هم الذين يرتكبون
هذه المجازر بحق
القوى الامنيه والعسكريه وبحق المدنيين
السوريين هناك تقارير ل منظمات الامم
المتحده هناك تقارير اعلاميه تتحدث عن هذا
الموضوع انما ايضا هناك الروايه التي
تقدمها الحكومه السوريه وهناك ايضا
الروايه التي يتم تتم
بالتناقص بين الاصدقاء بين من يعرف
الكثيرين وانا منهم من مدينه حمص الذين
يتحدثون عن مجازر ترتكب
بحقد من قبل هذه المجموع الاص من والروايه
الرسميه او روايه المتظاهرين او الثوار او
المعارضه اتحدث عما قاله الرئيس الاسد هو
قال بالحرف انا لا املك البلد انا رئيس
هذا ما قاله لو كان تصريح مكتوبا لربما
كان جاز القول بانه محرف ولكن كلنا سمعنا
باذني ما قال بالحرف قال انا لا املك
البلد انا رئيس وعندما سئل حتى اين يعتق
عندما سئل عن اعتقال الاطفال قال وير يعني
اين بالانجليزيه عندما سئل عن قشوش الذي
عندما حاول ان يغني مطالبا باسقاطه انتزعت
حنجرته قال لم اسمع به في حياتي عندما سئل
عن رسام كاريكاتور الذي ضرب قال انا لا
اعرف هذا لم يحرف هذا ما قال له مترجم من
الانجليزيه ويمكنك ان تعود الى المقابله
نفسها باللغه الانجليزيه ان كنت لا تصدق
ما نقوله وما نترجمه نحن انا لم اقل ان
هذا الامر تم تحريفه من قبلكم انا قلت
بالتحديد ان هذا الموضوع اذيع خارج السياق
لاني رايت عندكم وعلى فضائيات اخرى وعلى
محطات تلفزيونيه حتى محليه لبنانيه اخرى
ايه نقل لهذا الكلام بطريقه غير دقيقه
بالقول ان الرئيس الاسد انه تنص من
المسؤوليه وانه لا علاقه له عندما يقول
قوا تابعه للحكومه الا يكون تناص من
المسؤوليه سيد عبيد عندما يقول يعني حتى
لا يضيع وقت الحلقه فقط هكذا عندما يقول
القوات تابعه للحكومه وهو بحسب الدستور
راس الدوله رئيس جمهوريه منتخب تشمل
سلطاته تعيين رئيس الوزراء والوزراء وهو
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه عندما يقول
ليست القوات تابعه لما تابعه الحكومه وهو
من يعين هذه الحكومه اليس هذا تن وصلا من
المسؤوليه بحسب الدستور السوري
نفسه انت تطرحين الاسئله وتجيبين عليها
انا الذي يجب ان اجيب على الاس انا اقول
رايي في هذا الموضوع ان الرئيس الاسد
يتحدث من موقع انه رئيس البلاد وهو ليس
ملكا وهذا امر لصالح الرئيس الاسد وليس
ضده لانه لا يملك الجيش ولا يملك القوى
الامنيه كما هو الوضع في البلدان ال ذات
الانظمه الملكيه هو رئيس للجمهوريه هناك
حكومه هناك قيادات امنيه هناك قيادات
عسكريه هي التي تتابع الامور على الارض
انما في الواقع عندما تطلق النار من قبل
المسلحين على قوى الجيش والامن من الطبيعي
ان ترد هذه القوى ومن الممكن ان يسقط
ضحايا في هذا الموضوع من الطرفين مدنيين
وبالتالي كل من يسقط بالنهايه هو ضحيه
سوريه لهذا الصراع الدموي القائم والذي
تلعب فيه القوى الاصوليه المسلحه على
الارض دورا رئيسيا في تاج جيج الوضع بدات
الامور على مستوى الاصلاح السياسي ثم
انتقلت الى محاوله التدويل ثم الى التعريب
ثم الى التتريك والان دخلنا في محاوله
لادخال سوريا في حرب اهليه لا نهايه لها
تؤدي بالتالي الى تقسيم سوريا ولن يكون
هناك نظام بديل عن هذا النظام لديه القدره
لاعاده توحيد سوريا او
ل يعني ايجاد الامن والاستقرار على
المستوى الداخلي السوري طيب تركتك حدث
ولكن كل بكل اجابتك لن تجبني عن نقطه بانه
هو بحسب الدستور السوري مره جديده اكرر لك
هو القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه هو لم يتنصل من هذا الامر ولم يقل
انه ليس القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
انما قال عندما حدثته المذيعه و وحضرتك
تفضلت بهذا النص نص الحوار كاملا بانه هو
قال لها عندما سالته بعض الامور انه لم
يسمع بها لان هناك الكثير من الفبركات
الاعلاميه حول قتل هناك طفل قتل ساري سعود
الذي قتل منذ عده ايام وقيل ان من قتله هو
قوى النظام وتبين حتى من والدته ان من
قتله هو المجموعات الاصوليه المسلحه
الموجوده على الارض لانه من طائفه اخرى
عندما هاجموا المنطقه التي يتواجد فيها
هناك فلم يسمع بابراهيم قشوش الذي انتزعت
حنجرته فقط
لانه غنى منادي باسقاطه او تجرا على
ذلك لم يسمع به انا ايضا لم اسمع به اذا
كان هناك من امور لم نسمع بها تزاع هنا
وهناك على على بعض المحطات او على بعض
مواقع
الانترنت صحيحه هذه الامور طيب هل من
الطبيعي ان تكون معلومات رئيس الجمهوريه
في
البلاد عن مواطنيه وعما يحدث كمعلومات انت
في لبنان كمحلل
لماذا لا هناك وسائل الاعلام مفتوحه لكل
الناس وهناك تقارير يتم التداول بها على
مواقع الانترنت وعلى محطات التلفزيون
ويوما بعد يوم يتبين ان هذه التقارير جزء
كبير منها مشوه جزء كبير منها ك كبيرل
انتقل الى السيد عمر ادلبي من القاهره سيد
ادلبي ما تعليقك اولا على هذه
المقابله والله تقرا هذه المقابله تقرا
فيها مؤشرات عديده ابرز هذه المؤشرات ان
هلعا وخوفا ورعبا حقيقيين يعني يشعر بهم
الرئيس بشار الاسد او ما يسمى الان رئيس
بشار الاسد يشعر من ان مصيرا يواجهه كمصير
سلوبودان موزو فيتش عندما
تتحدث يعني المجلس حقوق الانسان عن جرائم
ضد الانسانيه ارتكبت في سوريا وهو راس هرم
هذه السلطه هذه من ناحيه النقطه الاخرى
التي يمكن ان تقرا من هذه المقابله ان
النظام يعاني فعلا عزله عالميه وعربيه
استدعت منه تعيين ناطق باسم الخارجيه
واستدعت من رئيسه ان يتحدث الى وسائل
الاعلام
ليعني ليدلي علينا بمثل هذه الاكاذيب
والسخافات المساله الثالثه وهي في غايه
الاهميه ان راس هذا النظام وعصابته
مستعدون دائما لتخلي عن القاده العسكريين
والافراد من الضباط الجيش والامن عن تخلي
عنهم وتحميلهم مسؤوليه ما يجري في سوريا
من جرائم وهذه النقاط في غايه الاهميه احب
ان اشير اليها المساله الثانيه التي يمكن
ان نقراها من هذه المقابله اليوم يعني
رئيس يمثل في النظام الرئاسي كامل يعني
يمنحه الدستور مطلق الصلاحيات هذا من
ناحيه هو رئيس او القائد العام للجيش
والقوات المسلحه ان لم يكن هو من اطلق ال
نار فمن اطلقها ومن امر باطلاقها ان وهو
في نفس الوقت رئيس المجلس الاعلى للقضاء
في سوريا وهو لم يحاسب مجرما واحدا من
نظامه اطلق النار على الناس في هذ في
هاتين الحالتين ماذا يفعل بس بشار الاسد
على راس السلطه في سوريا سي كان لم يسمع
بحدثه علي فرزات ولم يسمع بابراهيم قاشوش
نعم في هاتين النقطتين التبرير هو ان
الجيش عندما يطلق النار يكون يدافع عن
نفسه في وجه من تسميه الروايه الرسميه
السوريه جماعات مسلحه ارهابيه
وبانه جرت محاسبه اخطاء فرديه كما وصفها
ارتكبت جرى محاسبه
هؤلاء هذا كلام عار عن الصحه تماما اخطاء
فرديه تسقط 5000 شهيد في سوريا يعني
الاخطاء الفرديه يمكن ان تحدث عن حادثه
اثنتان ثلاث ا 10 اما ان نتحدث عن 5000
شهيد سقطوا في سوريا باخطاء فرديه يعني
هذا كلام لا يصدقه عاقل على وش الارض هذه
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى عندما
يتحد حس حسنا نحن وهو مختلفان من حيث
المبدا على عدد الشهداء الذين سقطوا في
سوريا وعن الجهه التي تسقط هؤلاء فليكن
بيننا حكم عادل مستقل حر هو الاعلام ولجان
ولجان تحقيق مستقله هل تمنع المعارضه
والقوى الثوريه دخول هذه اللجان ودخول هذا
الاعلام ام يمنعها النظام ليخفي جرائمه
اذا الروا بحد ذاتها روايه متهالكه بائسه
لا يصدقها احد وعندما يقول بشار الاسد ان
من يرتكب هذا الفعل ان ان يعني ان حصل هو
شخص مجنون فنحن نؤكد نعم هو شخص مجنون
ومجرم وهو يمثل هذه الصفه بالذات وانا هنا
لا اشتم انا هنا اوصف واقع حال طيب ولكن
هو المقابل ايض اخى احب ان اشير نعم فقط
في المقابل هو اشار الى انه لو لم يكن
لديه دعم شعبي لو لم تكن لديه شعبيه لتنحى
فورا و ما بقي في
منصبه بالتاكيد هناك شعبيه لبشار الاسد
لدى مؤيديه الذين لا يرون في في في سيل
الدم الذي يجري في سوريا شيئا يعني ما
دامت مصالحهم متحققه سواء كانت مصالحهم
الطبقيه ام الطائفيه هذا امر صرنا في
سوريا متاكدين منه تماما عندما يخرج في
احدى الجمعه اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين متظاهر
في سوريا التي يتنازعها الان جيش وا و
شبيحه تقتل من دون يعني من دون استثناء
منذ يعني من الطفل الذي عمره شهرين الى
السيده التي توفيت الان في م اليوم في
مدينه الحوله بسبب عدم توفر الدواء لها
بسبب محاصره هذه المدينه وعمرها 70 سنه
عندما ينزل هذا الرقم فاعتقد ان خيار
الشعب واضح تماما باتجاه من وخيار الشعب
واضح بانه اسقط شرعيه هذا النظام واسقط
شرعيه هذه العصابه التي تحكم هذا البلد
وعلى راسها بشار الاسد ابقى معنا سيد عمر
ادلبي ايضا يبقى معنا السيد محمد عبيد من
بيروت ولكن بعد هذا الفاصل القصير سنواصل
[موسيقى]
الحلقه اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناول مضامين حديث الرئيس السوري لشبكه
اي بي سي الامريكيه سيد محمد عبيد عندما
سالته بربرا وترز لرئيس الاسد ان كان يشعر
بالذنب لصور القتلى او لمن سقط من قتلى بغ
النظر عن الاعداد ابتسم وقال لا هو راس
الدوله وبغض النظر من قتل من بغض النظر عن
هويه الضحيه بالنهايه قتيل
سوري هل يمكن فهم او تبرير انه لا يشعر
بالذنب
برايك انا اعتقد ليست المساله انه يشعر
بالذنب او لا يشعر هو يعني اجتزت حضرتك
الكلام ايضا عندما هو قال استكمالا لهذا
الحديث انه لا يشعر بالذنب لانه يبذل
قصاره جهده لمعالجه هذا الموضوع بذل قصار
جهد عب اعذرني على المقاطعه ولكن عندما
تكون في موقع مسؤول راس الدوله عندما يبدو
القصاره جهده حتى ولو كانت نواياه صافيه
وبذل قصار جهده ورغم ذلك سقط قتله اذا على
الاقل هو فشل في قصار جهده هذا وان لم يكن
مسؤولا عن القتل فهو على الاقل مسؤولا في
منع القتل وبالتالي هنا ياتي شعور الذنب
سواء كان قاتلا ام
فاشلا منع القتل تتم معالجته على الارض من
خلال مواجهه المجموعات الاصوليه المسلحه
المنتشره في اكثر من منطقه كانت في سوريا
وتم حصرها الان في محيط مدينه حمص وعلى
اطرافها يعني في ريف مدينه حمص وعلى
اطرافها حيث هناك اكثر من 1000 مسلح
ينتشرون ويعملون قتلا بالمدنيين على اسباب
لاسباب طائفيه ومذهب وايضا ايض ينالون من
دوريات او مجموعات الجيش المتحركه والقوى
الامنيه حتى على الطريق بين تدمر وبين حمص
جرى اغتيال سبعه طيارين منذ فتره من حوالي
منذ حوالي ع ايام لا يعني هذه الامور لا
يعني لا يتم بثها لا يتم الاعلان عنها لا
يتم التصريح بها ولا يتم اي الترويج لها
في جميع المحطات التلفزيونيه الرئيس الاسد
الرئيس الدكتور بشار الاسد مسؤول ال الاول
في سوريا وهو مسؤول عن كل الشعب السوري
حتى المخطئ منهم وبالتالي هو يعالج الامور
بالطريقه التي يمكن ان تحفظ استقرار البلد
ان تحفظ وحدته الداخليه ان تمنع الحرب
الاهليه ان تمنع الصراع الطائفي والمذهبي
الذي اكتوى به لبنان والعراق ودول اخرى في
المنطقه لا يجب ان تتم المساله يعني ليس
هو شخصا عاديا كي نقول له انه يحس بالذنب
او لا يحس بالذنب ل ليس من الطبيعي ان
يستقيل مثلا كما يطرح البعض او ان يتنحى
كما يطالب البعض لانه فشل هو لم يفشل هو
يحاول مداراه الامور ومعالجتها بالطرق
الهادئه التي تقلل من الخسائر الان
المشكله وقعت هناك اكثر من 1ف مسلح في تلك
المنطقه في حمص ومحيطه هل المطلوب من
الجيش ان يح عفوا هل المطلوب من الجيش انح
تلك المنطقه ويدمرها ليزيد القتلى ام
يعالج الامر بالطرق الامنيه المنا
لمحاوله اعاده الاستقرار اليها لنقول
لنسلم جدلا ان هناك الف مسلح هناك 100 الف
مسلح حتى كيف سمح لهؤلاء بين هلالين
المسلحين بالتغلغل في سوريا على هذه
الشاكله بدون اي وجع ضمير او ذنب وبان
يعني تفعل ما تفعل بحسب الروايه الرسميه
السوريه علما ان سوريا تقول ان لديها
سيادتها وهذا ما ردته في المبادره العربيه
وتكرره دائما لديها جيش قوي جدا جيش وطني
لديها اجهزه امنيه قويه جدا وهذه الاجهزه
الامنيه متعديه ربما تعرفها اكثر مني انت
هذه هذا السؤال ينطبق ايضا مثلا على دوله
مثل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
يتغلغل اليها او يتسلل اليها اي
المكسيكيون هذه يعني مساله الحدود بين
الدول خصوصا في منطقتنا بين مثلا لبنان
وسوريا بين تركيا وسوريا بعد الانفتاح
الذي حصل منذ سنوات قليله بين البلدين
وتجاوز الكثير من العوائق الحدوديه بين
الاردن وسوريا بين العراق الذي كان يعيش
تحت الاحتلال وهو حتى اليوم تحت الاحتلال
وهناك مجموعات اصوليه في العراق كانت تفجر
كل
يوم الحدود م قابله للضبط 100% اذا كان
هذا هو الحال لما الحديث عن اصلاحات
اصلاحات لمن لهذه الجماعات
الارهابيه لا هؤلاء لا يمثلون هؤلاء لا
يمثلون واحد او اثنين او في احسن الحالات
5% مع من يدعمهم في الداخل من السوريين
غالبيه الشعب السوري تؤكد يوما بعد يوم
انها ضد الفرز الطائفي والمذهبي انها مع
وحده سوريا انها مع الاستقرار وهي ايضا
وانا ايضا مع الاصلاح مع الاصلاح الجذري
للنظام السياسي السوري انما على قاعده
التعدديه السياسيه على قاعده فتح المجال
لاعلام حر وانتخابات ديمقراطيه حره
الره المعارضه وتشارك في هذه العمليه
السياسيه سيد ادلبي من القاهره ردا ايضا
على سؤال حول ما قالت عنه الامم المتحده
عن الجرائم ضد الانسانيه قال ليس هنالك اي
اثبات قدم للحكومه السوريه وقال وقالت له
المذيعه ان سوريا عضو في الامم المتحده
ولديها سفير هنا قال هذه لعبه نلعبها وهذا
لا يعني اننا نصدقها هل تعتقد ان ايضا على
هذه القاعده لعبه نلعبها وهذا لا يعني ان
نصدقها هذه القاعده ايضا مطبقه على
التعاطي السوري الرسمي مع المبادره
العربيه وجهود الجامعه العربيه لحل الازمه
لعبه
نلعبها بالتاكيد سيدتي هذا ما يحصل
تماما لنعود الى نص المبادره العربيه او
الى بنود المبادره العربيه التي قدمها
وزراء الخارجيه العرب في اتفاقهم الشهير
يوم الثاني من شهر نوفمبر الماضي هذه
المبادره تنص على اربع بنود ياتي في
طليعتها وقف القتل و وقف القتل والعنف
وسحب المظاهر المسلحه واطلاق سراح
المعتقلين والسماح لوفد من المراقبين
والاعلام الحر بالدخول الى سوريه جرى
تقزيم كل هذه المبادره في بند واحد هو بند
بعثه المراقبين النظام يلعب على هذا البند
منذ اكثر من شهرين واسقط خلال شهر نوفمبر
وحده
823 قتيلا برصاص قوات امن وعصاباته من من
الجيش والشب بح اذا هذا النظام نعم يلعب
على فكره انه عضو في هذه الجامعه ويتحدث
عن التضامن العربي ولكنه يسخف في الحقيقه
يستخف بهذه المبادره اطلق ابواق من
المحللين السياسيين والاعلاميين وحتى
مندوب سوريا في جامعه الدول العربيه ليهين
هذه الجامعه ويهين الوزراء الخارجيه العرب
الذين اتفقوا على هذا القرار ويعود الان
ليتحدث عن استعداده لتوقيع بروتوكول دخول
بعثه المراقبين الامر ينطبق بالضبط على
الامم المتحده التي يس خف ارقامها
وتقاريرها اليوم طيب كيف تفسر جهاد كلام
جهاد مقدسي عندما تر للاعلان بعد مقابله
الاسد بان يعني وكانه يحاول ان يفسر
مقابله الاسد او ان يحاول ان يوضح الامور
باختصار لو
سمحت يعني من حيث يعني من حيث المبدا
تعيين ناطق باسم وزاره الخارجيه السوريه
دليل على ارتباك هذا النظام واستعداده او
رغبته اليوم بان ينتقي وجوها ليست يعني
يعني ليست من هذه الوجوه التي سئمنا منها
في الاعلام السوري الرسمي ليقول كلاما
مفيدا وهو يعني لا يمتلك موضوعا يتحدث فيه
موضوعا مفيدا يحاول الان ان يفسر كلام
بشار الاسد بالالتفاف ايضا على هذه
التصريحات التي تبدو واضحه تماما في اتجاه
رفع المسؤوليه عن شخص بشار الاسد ومحاوله
تحويلها للقاده الاصغر الذين ستطال م يد
العداله بالتاكيد هم وسهم في مرحله قادمه
ان شاء الله شكز من القاهره عمر ادلبي عضو
المجلس الوطني السوري المعارض ايضا اشكر
الكاتب الصحفي اللبناني حدثنا من بيروت
السيد محمد عبيت شكرا جزيلا لكما وشكرا
لكم مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا باذن
الله قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
e